hello
in this video we'll talk about grum
staining
gram staining is a method which was
devised by hans christian graham
at 1884.
so it's a pretty old technique this
particular staining method can
discriminate between gram positive
bacteria from the gram negative bacteria
gram-positive bacteria has
thick mesh-like cell wall which stains
purple by crystal violet in contrast the
gram-negative bacteria have thinner
layer which cannot retain the purple
stain of crystal violet and get
counterstained by saffroning
this might sounds bit alien at this
moment but till the end of this video
this would be super clear let me walk
you through the step of these staining
protocol
so this
staining starts with smearing our slide
with a patient-derived sample or sample
from any other places
so with a small swab
you can put your
sample on the slide
then the step
next step
is to heat fix the slide by gently
moving the slide over a bunsen burner
then in the second step
we have to use primary stain
in this case crystal violet act like a
primary stain
so crystal violet gets inserted into the
cell wall and thereby
it can stain the cell wall of the
bacteria
so first we add the crystal violet and
incubate about a minute or so this time
and protocol might be variable a little
bit but overall the steps remain the
same
after this incubation process
the bacteria should stain purple in
color if they are gram positive or even
they are gram negative everybody would
stain purple
now then we add a iodine
solution
this iodine acts like a moderator it
allows the crystal violet to be trapped
inside
the cell wall so this iodine and crystal
violet complex
makes it kind of more rigid and
fix it inside the cell wall
so the complex is fairly large and it
cannot be washed away with water and
it's insoluble in water
now we add a decolorization agent most
commonly ethanol or acetone
so when we
wash this particular slide with
decolorization reagent
there would be further loss of
water from the cell wall and this cell
wall becomes literally impermeable for
the
iodine and crystal violet compound
so this complex can not actually
be released from the cell wall and it's
retained into the cell wall of a gram
positive bacteria it has a fairly thick
cell wall
in contrast
in gram negative bacteria
the cell wall is pretty thin
and this particular organism cannot hold
the crystal violet iodine complex and
the decolorizing agent
wash it away
so in the next step when counterstain
happens
then saffronin can stain this particular
gram negative organism but not the gram
positive organism so the gram positive
bacteria would remain violet color
whereas
the gram
negative bacteria will be stained as
reddish or kind of like pinkish in this
particular stain
so by looking at the color we can
clearly discriminate
gram positive bacteria from a gram
negative bacteria
so this was the overall summary of this
particular process
now
let me tell you the applications of gram
staining in the field of medical
microbiology
so obviously it can discriminate between
gram positive infections from a gram
negative infection for example most
common gram positive infections are
staphylococcus aureus infection
streptococcus
etc whereas gram negative infections
like salmonella pneumonia urinary tract
infection all of these things happen due
to gram negative bacteria this is kind
of like very generalistic uh statement
but
what we can understand that from gram
staining that there could be a class of
bacteria which are which is which might
be pathogenic and for can be found in
patient sample
it might be gram positive or negative
based on that a clinician can understand
okay which antibiotic to choose for the
treatment purpose
now gram staining is not the
confirmatory test for a diagnosis
purpose it is just a screening step it's
a first pass screening which can be done
easily without any sophisticated
instrumentation and that's the biggest
advantage of gram staining
now gram staining has several
disadvantages as well for example gram
staining does not work properly on acid
fast organism let me give you a clear
example
so it won't act on mycobacterium
tuberculosis that well
so this acid fast bacteria has thick
mycolic acid in their
cell wall and that doesn't allow the
gram stain to penetrate
so
even
it has to be stained with a different
kind of
staining method such as acid fast
staining if you want to learn more about
acid fast training you can click on the
i button right now
now gram staining is pretty much
applicable for those bacteria which has
cell wall i mean most bacteria does have
cell wall but
bacterias like microplasma who don't
have any cell wall
they would not be stained with gram
staining right
there must be some other kind of
methodology to detect these kind of
microplasma in laboratory so if you want
to learn more about microplasma and
microplasma infection you can click on
the i button
but despite of all these disadvantages
gram staining is easy to perform cost
effective and that's why it is
frequently used in medical microbiology
lab
so i hope this video was useful you can
get a note regarding this topic in my
facebook page
for which the link is given in the
description box
and as usual don't forget to like share
and subscribe you can support me on
patreon if you're a indian viewer you
can
actually uh use this qr code to support
my channel your small support means a
lot my courses are also present in an
academy which is india's uh online
learning platform
you can use my code ap 10 to get a 10
percent discount and i'm presenting all
the social media so you can follow me on
social media get in touch with me i
would be really happy to answer your
questions thank you